marilyn monroe alien hybrids and
whatever the hell this is american
horror story's second death valley
episode has dropped and it is a marked
improvement over the first filled with
even more clues as to what's going on
including how death valley and red tide
are linked we're not going to be wasting
any time there's a lot to cover here so
make sure to hit that like and subscribe
button because here we go we're in palm
springs 1963. nine years after the
events of last episode which saw
president dwight eisenhower come into
contact with both an alien entity and
the long missing amelia earhart
eisenhower is no longer president and
his former vice president richard nixon
is sweating it out because he fears
current president john f kennedy will
find out about the secret treaty they
made with the aliens the sweating dick
nixon and yes i never thought i'd say
sweating dick is a reference to richard
nixon's debate against kennedy in 1960
which was the first televised debate
ever and saw nixon sweating profusely
due to the hot camera lights and
improper makeup it's actually considered
one of the main things that lost nixon
the election nixon doesn't trust kennedy
he's a catholic and democrat which he
has disdained for but as mimi eisenhower
will later reveal nixon has ulterior
motives he wants to become president and
if ike is labeled as some sort of
traitor with the fact he made a deal
with aliens that sacrificed american
lives well you can believe he'd never
stand a chance at being president so
eisenhower nixon decided to get ahead of
things and speak with the president
directly showing him confidential papers
about the crash in 54. now there's some
really cool information if you read part
of the confidential dossier found here
it talks about a colony established only
by males it also uses the word adam and
eve plus a mention of god the whole
thing kind of hints that we're not the
descendants of god but of aliens which
could be why eisenhower who usually
started his meetings with a prayer
decides not to sing
that's when we had something to pray to
the basics of this alien treaty are as
follows in exchange for 5 000 abductions
a year the american government will be
given access to advanced tech allowing
them to dominate the world we see some
of this tech later on in the episode
subject one also known as maria shows
them a device which can triple the speed
of electronic devices and a metal box
made from material that can't be picked
up by radar mimi eisenhower even remarks
how great their salisbury microwave
dinner was and it heated up in only 30
seconds some of you may have even
noticed the movie playing on screen as
space master x7 which ironically was
billed as a double feature alongside
vincent price's the fly president
kennedy expresses his concerns to
marilyn monroe who he was having an
affair with but monroe died in 1962 and
this is set in 1963. is this merely a
writer's error or is something else
going on here amelia earhart returned
not having aged a day since her
disappearance in 1937 and will later
meet calico who hasn't aged a day since
the 60s perhaps this is all connected
well marilyn doesn't seem too concerned
about the aliens as a child she had an
experience where a teddy bear was beamed
down to her bedroom she had no idea
where it came from in past preview
footage we've seen marilyn visited by
aliens so there is some sort of
connection here but the fact marilyn
wants kennedy to tell the american
people the truth hints that she's not in
cahoots with whatever entity took
control of subject one we go back nine
years to 1954 where eisenhower is
president he's convened a meeting with
top military advisors on what to do
about this treaty on the one hand they
are surrendering their sovereignty but
on the other they risk the aliens going
to russia should they not accept they
are interrupted by subject one who tells
them that the alien world is dying but
we never find out what it's dying from
which i think is very interesting they
need to abduct humans and create some
sort of hybrid since the aliens haven't
evolved to combat our planet's toxins
and viruses their test subject was
amelia earhart and as we'll see later
that didn't really pan out so the aliens
need more candidates whatever entity is
controlling subject one explodes her own
head after he or she is done with it but
before this happens we get a small
glimpse at the entity's real voice just
like we did in the last episode
time is running out
for both our people i don't know about
you guys but i'm putting my money on
cody fern being the person controlling
these people we know he's been cast this
season and according to wikipedia and
yes wikipedia isn't a reliable source he
may be playing valiant thor an alien who
represented an intergalactic high
council who regularly met with
eisenhower you can see an uncanny
resemblance between fern in the preview
footage and this shot of thor eisenhower
expresses his concerns about the treaty
to his wife mimi whose only big concern
at the moment is organizing her birthday
and yes her big birthday celebrations
covered by the media help popularize
birthday celebrations amongst american
adults mimi really wants ike to accept
the treaty and that's because as we'll
see in a bit she's being controlled by
the aliens so eisenhower's eventual
acceptance of this treaty is coerced
seeing as the alien would have killed
mimi should he not have accepted maybe
even goes behind ike's back asking nixon
to convince eisenhower to take the deal
nixon even proposes they could accept
the deal then use the alien tech against
them to force them back not sure if that
plotline is where the show is headed now
i gotta say the present day segment in
this episode was a lot better than last
week's our four pregnant friends are on
their way to see jaime's doctor dr rayas
the same doctor she's had since she was
19 and she says this doctor is discreet
remember last episode it was hinted that
jaime may have had an abortion when she
was 19. so it makes sense they go to
someone who is discreet in case they all
need to get rid of this alien inside of
them things take a turn when the doctor
finds two heartbeats it could mean twins
but on the ultrasound we really only see
one alien-like creature could the
ultrasound just be picking up one or
could the alien have two hearts and what
is this weird floating thing the
appointment is cut short when a bunch of
literal men in black storm the office
and abduct our gang of four they're
injected with this green laser thing
which knocks them unconscious this is
likely tech from the aliens kendall
wakes up attached to this weird advice
floating in a room with other pregnant
people i guess in last week's preview
footage they hadn't completed the vfx
yet as you can see the boards they're
laying on we get our first glimpse of
angelica ross's character theta who
seems to be a half human half alien
hybrid she tells kendall that the thing
inside her is hope for the future and an
opportunity to save a planet kendall is
put back to sleep seemingly via mind
control or whatever it is she's
connected to we're then introduced to
this white cafeteria area where
nutritious jelly cubes are brought out
giving the total apocalypse vibes now
this is supposed to be present day yet
steve jobs is here steve jobs died in
2011. does this have something to do
with time as i previously mentioned or
is death valley completely fiction steve
is talking to leslie grossman's
character calico it's heavily implied
that steve is one of these alien hybrids
as he shows his disdain for other such
hybrids who squander their talents he
talks about one of them using a pencil
which he doesn't like since he probably
prefers digital and calico even says she
once saw one of the hybrids use their
talents for shooting ping pong balls out
of their well you know that's actually a
nod to season 4's freak show where
desiree dupri said the same thing to
elsa mars so it seems as though these
hybrids are talented and we get this
really quick shot of a man administering
what seems to be black pills to our
abductees is there something these pills
react to when combined with an alien
fetus something that makes them talented
like how we saw the pill create talented
people in red tide the other interesting
thing here is calico's claim that she
hasn't aged a day since she got here
likely in the 1960s she's not a quote
one and done and they appear to keep her
around for breeding purposes which begs
the question what happens to those who
are one and done are they killed or are
they brought back to earth with no
memory of what happened but i want to
get back to this aging thing calico
hasn't aged and what was the last line
that chemist says to baby eli at the end
of red tide i'm gonna move on to another
place
create another drug
maybe one that'll make you and i live
forever that she might go and make a
pill so that they can live forever the
pill has been used in promo material as
the thing that bridges red tide and
death valley together and i can't help
but think something much bigger is going
on here after troy refuses to take the
pills he's brought in to meet theta his
concern is where does the baby come out
of will it be his mouth his stomach or
some place far more painful theta says
the line life must find its own way
which is very similar to jeff goldblum's
line in jurassic park life finds a way
jeff goldblum started the 1986 version
of the fly which the double feature
mamie and ike were watching was based on
lots of cool little easter eggs like
that throughout the episode later today
i hope to be coming out with the episode
9 preview breakdown yes we only have two
more episodes of this season so i hope
you'll stick around for that but i also
want to hear your thoughts and theories
below on what could happen next thanks
for watching everyone make sure to like
and subscribe and for more bad takes you
can always follow me on twitter and
instagram at thingstoryt until next time
remember daddy loves you very much
you